[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un accord de paix historique c'est ainsi
que donald trump a qualifié l'accord
trouvé entre israël et les émirats
arabes unis sous l'égide des états unis
à benyamin netanyahu parle d'une journée
historique pour les deux pays
alors que l'accord prévoie qu'israël
suspende ses projets de l'annexion de
territoires palestiniens attention en
méditerranée orientale la france
renforce la présence militaire dans la
zone un bras de fer demeurent entre la
turquie et la grèce
après la découverte de vastes gisements
gaziers ankara vient d'y envoyer des
navires sismiques pour prospecter ce qui
est vécu par la grèce comme une nouvelle
provocation
en france la menace d'une deuxième vague
plane toujours avec des chiffres en
hausse 2669 cas confirmés ces dernières
24 heures dans le monde les grandes
puissances poursuivent la course au
vaccin tout comme l'indonésie le mexique
ou encore l'argentine après l'annnonce
de la russie de l'enregistrement d'un
vaccin pour la première fois au monde
les critiques se multiplient
[Musique]
il est 20h heure de paris bonsoir et
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez en
directe ur rt france les émirats arabes
unis et israël ont signé sous l'égide
des états unis un accord de paix il
permet ainsi à ces deux pays de
normaliser leurs relations selon les
mots de donald trump
il y à quelques instants j'ai organisé
un appel très important avec deux amis
le premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou et le prince héritier des
émirats arabes unis mohamed bin zayed où
ils ont convenu de finaliser un accord
de paix historique
tout le monde a dit que ce serait
impossible
et comme vous le savez mohamed est l'un
des grands dirigeants au moyen-orient
après 49 ans israël et les émirats
arabes unis normaliseront pleinement
leurs relations diplomatiques
une journée historique a réagi le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
netanyahu ajoutant que l'annexion de pan
de cisjordanie est reportée mais qu'il
n'y avait pas renoncé de son côté le
prince héritier d'abou dhabi mohammed
bin zayed se félicite de l' échange
téléphonique avec ces derniers
lors d'un appel avec le président trump
et le premier ministre netanyahu
un accord a été conclu pour stopper
l'annexion par israël des territoires
palestiniens
les émirats arabes unis et israël ont
également convenu de coopérer de définir
une feuille de route pour
l'établissement d'une relation
bilatérale
et puis mahmoud abbas le chef de
l'autorité palestinienne annonce
convoqué une réunion d'urgence de la
direction palestinienne
de son côté le mouvement palestinien
hamas a réagi il rejette et condamne cet
accord qui selon lui ne sert pas la
cause palestinienne il est considéré je
cite comme une continuation du d
ni des droits du peuple palestinien et
pour en parler à didier billion
directeur adjoint de l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques est avec nous didier
billion bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors israël et les émirats arabes unis
on le disait ont annoncé avoir conclu un
accord de paix qualifiée d'historique
par donald trump notamment mais il ya
déjà eu des rapprochements précédemment
entre ces deux états n'est ce pas oui en
fait fait lé point d'aboutissement d'un
très long processus parce que nous
savons que depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années
monsieur 30 et bien sûr mais la ligne
est à méo cherchait à tout prix a essayé
de de se rapprocher des états arabes du
golfe notamment des émirats arabes unis
parce que ahmed ben zayed a la
réputation d'être un stratège et de
raisonner sur le moyen terme ce qui est
plus que dans la région donc c'était
clairement une volonté de rapprochement
on se souvient aussi que les émirats
arabes unis a vécu un rôle assez
important dans la promotion du fameux
plantes rome qui a été annoncé
publiquement au mois dé janvier dernier
donc l'établissement de ces relations
diplomatiques n'est pas un petit
événement il faut le prendre en tant que
tel je ne suis pas certain qu'ils soient
historiques comme monsieur 30 le dis
très rapidement mais en tout cas c'est
un événement d'un dut grande importance
politique mais pour autant cela ne règle
rien sur le fond c'est à dire que on
peut constater une nouvelle fois que les
principaux concernés notamment sur la
question palestinienne à savoir les
dirigeants palestiniens n'ont
visiblement pas été du tout concertée
donc en réalité cet accord scelle un
processus était déjà alors comme je lé
brièvement rappelé mais ce rapprochement
ne permet en outre pas de régler sur le
fond la question palestinienne la
création d'un état palestinien viable
et l'association définitif de tout
processus d'annexion puisque je rappelle
que dans fait d'accord et dans cet
établissement de relations diplomatiques
monsieur ben aminé qui nous a promis
qu'il le suspende est n'a pas dit qu'il
arrêtait définitivement et kitsch et
stands est d'accord on va y revenir
justement didier billion mais alors s'il
n'ya pas de changement sur le fond comme
vous venez de nous le dire pour autant
qu'elle changement cet accord peut-il
apporter pour les deux pays et pour le
moyen-orient alors c'est l'expression je
pense de modification de deux rapports
de force géopolitique fait très
important parce que ce dont personne ne
parle enfin d'admirer les tombée il ya
tout récemment donc nous n'avons pas
encore eu le temps de réfléchir
totalement aux conséquences que cela
peut avoir
et moi j'aimerais vous dire deux mots
sur l'iran parce qu'on sait très bien
que l une des obsessions
d'administration autre homme
c'est d'isoler de continuer la pression
sur téhéran et d'isoler toujours plus ni
l'iran or il est évident qu'un
rapprochement codifiée par
l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques entre deux états l'état
d'israël d'une part et un état arabe
d'autre part les émirats arabes unis est
un pas en avant dans cette volonté
d'établir une sorte de cordon de
sécurité de plus en plus strictes au
tour de l'iran ça fait très important
et en ce sens c'est établissement de
relations diplomatiques prochaine à la
modification à la codification de la
modification des rapports de force de
géopolitique et à la réorganisation des
alliances géopolitique régionale ça fait
très important alors l'un des principaux
éléments de l'accord était censé être le
renoncement d'israël à l'annexion de
territoires palestiniens selon les
émirats à mais cela vient d'être
contredit par benyamin nétanyahou
il parle d'une annexion repoussé on le
disait et à laquelle israël ne renonce
pas alors comment les émirats arabes
unis peuvent-ils dans ces conditions
vendre cette normalisation avec l'état
hébreu
aux autres pays arabes et au monde
musulman finalement ça c'est la bonne
question qu'il faut se poser parce que
un des enjeux de ce l'établissement des
relations diplomatiques c'était de
savoir si les émirats arabes unis était
capable d'entraîner à leur suite
d'autres états et on pense bien
évidemment notamment à l'arabie saoudite
or nous savons par exemple parce que
l'arabie saoudite est un pays central
dans la dans la région nous savons que 6
mb/s ahmed bin salman une jeune prince
héritier serait très favorable à
l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques avec israël parce qu'il
considère pour sa part que la question
palestinienne doit passer pour pertes et
profits aux yeux de l'histoire
mais le problème c'est que son père qui
est toujours le roi régnant actuellement
en arabie sony n'est pas du tout sur la
même longueur d'onde et que les
saoudiens les leroy ça devient veut des
garanties fermes quant à la situation
définitive du processus d'annexion
on peut craindre d'ailleurs qui de ce
point de vue les émirats arabes unis et
jouets ou est accepté de jouer un jeu de
dupes c'est à dire que vous avez raison
signé contre ce que déclarent les
dirigeants émirati est ce que précise
monsieur netanyahu
il ya quand même pour le moins une
différence est ce que ce sera l'arrêt ou
la suspension simplement du processus
d'annexion
la différence est grande et c'est bien
sur ce point que tant qu'il ne sera pas
réglé je doute que les émirats arabes
unis puissent entraîner derrière eux
d'autres wettach je pense que les autres
états arabes ou bonne partie d'entre eux
voudront des garanties beaucoup plus
importante
donc tout cela est assez est assez
compliqué en tout cas ceux fournis à
s'humilier et que cet accord vient à
point nommé et constituer un joli cadeau
à monsieur propre dont on sait qu'il
n'est pas dans une situation compliquée
quand à sa réélection au mois de
novembre prochain et qu'il va pouvoir se
parer d'un véritable succès diplomatique
en tout cas de son point de vue en tout
ça pour conclure
didier billion nous en parlions tout à
leurs côtés palestiniens notamment le
hamas on ne veut pas entendre parler de
ce plan oui évidemment mais le amat de
ce point de vue a plutôt raison c'est à
dire que considérant que les
palestiniens n'ont même pas été convié
aux discussions de la même façon
rappelez vous qu'au mois de janvier
dernier quand messieurs trump avait
proclamé publiquement son fameux plan
incluant d'ailleurs la possibilité pour
les israéliens de procéder à l'élection
de de nombreuses colonies à partir du
1er juillet ce qui n'a pas été fait qui
montre que c'est très compliqué en tout
cas ce qui est clair est que dans chaque
grand rendez-vous qui concerne les
dangers pas italien et bien les premiers
concernés ne sont même pas convoqué en
ce sens ça ne pourra pas aboutir tant
que les palestiniens ni la direction
palestinienne ne sera pas réintégré de
plein droit dans la processus
souhaitable de négociations politiques
et diplomatiques alors je crains que
cela ne règle rien sur le front merci
beaucoup didier billion pour cet
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
directeur adjoint de l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques iris et on poursuit avec
les fortes tensions en méditerranée
orientale la découverte de vastes
gisements gaziers cristallise les
relations entre la turquie et la grèce
ankara a déployé un navire de recherche
sismique escorté par des bâtiments
militaires dans la zone
dans ce contexte la france dénonce les
décisions unilatérales de la turquie et
décide d'intervenir en renforçant sa
présence militaire sur place est les
précisions de clément hospital un navire
de recherches sismiques des pêchés au
large par la turquie en méditerranée
orientale
ce bateau doit explorer une zone dont
les sols sont riches en hydrocarbures
qui s'étend de la crête grande île
grecque au sud jusqu'à quelques
kilomètres de la station balnéaire
turque d'antalya ces gisements
potentiels attise les tensions avec les
pays riverains dont la grèce qui
revendique une zone maritime exclusive
attendant le qu'on se le dise le risque
d'accident est plus présent quand de
tels moyens militaires sont réunis dans
une
aussi confiné dans un tel cas la
responsabilité incombe à celui qui est à
l'origine de cette situation
nous restons fermes dans notre
engagement en faveur de la légalité
internationale et du pouvoir des
diplomaties pour résoudre les problèmes
les plus complexes
nous ne serons jamais ce qui aggraveront
la situation pourtant la retenue n'est
qu'un aspect de notre pouvoir
aucune provocation ne restera cependant
sans réponse
nous avons démontré que nous répondrons
si nous nous sentons obligés et nous le
ferons à nouveau si nécessaire
mais la turquie compte est la
délimitation de l'espace maritime
grecque
ankara conteste le fait que le rocher de
kastellorizo maïs pour les turcs eux
coller à ses côtes
servat délimiter son espace maritime et
donc son champ d'action ils revendiquent
une souveraineté maritime en se servant
de l'île de metz situé à deux kilomètres
des côtes turques et vous savez à quelle
distance de la grèce métropolitaine 580
km cela ne peut s'expliquer
rationnellement
cela n'a pas de sens le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan a demandé à
s'entretenir avec la chancelière
allemande angela merkel et le président
du conseil européen charles michel pour
chercher à apaiser les tensions en
méditerranée orientale
une première tentative d'exploration
turc avait été stoppée il ya quelques
semaines à la suite de pressions de
l'allemagne
de son côté la france a renforcé sa
présence militaire dans la zone
en déployant temporairement deux
chasseurs rafale en crète et deux
navires de la marine nationale en
méditerranée orientale
j'ai décidé de renforcer temporairement
la présence militaire française en
méditerranée orientale dans les
prochains jours en coopération avec les
partenaires européens dont la grèce le
chef de l'état a vivement critiqué ce
qu'ils considèrent comme des violations
de souveraineté grecque et chypriote par
la turquie au sujet de l'exploration de
ses ressources gazières et appelle les
deux frères ennemis de l'otan à se
concerter davantage pour apaiser les
tensions et pour dominique trinquant
ancien chef de la mission militaire
française à l'onu cette intervention est
pour la france une manière de montrer
son soutien à la grèce dans la recherche
d'une résolution de ce conflit
il y a eu une intervention des jeunes
madame merkel antérieur et qui a fait
reculer ankara est donc là il y à une
concertation européenne et il s'agit
simplement de montrer au président
erdogan qu'il a des moyens militaires
certes personne ne le conteste mais que
ce ne sont pas des moyens à utiliser
dans le différend qui oppose
actuellement la grèce et la turquie et
que la france comme les autres pays
européens sont solidaires de la grèce
pour essayer de résoudre ce problème de
façon diplomatique mais on ne on agit
aussi j'allais dire un peu embêtant la
carotte et le bâton il faut bien montrer
aussi qu'on va les moyens nous
militaires qui pourraient s'opposer et
reste permettre de rester solidaires
avec la grèce que la grèce ne se sentent
pas seuls dans cette crise la france au
chevet du liban la ministre française
des armes et florence parly effet
actuellement à beyrouth pour une visite
de soutien de son côté le parlement a
entériné aujourd'hui la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire dans la
capitale
une réunion sous tension pour les
députés libanais rond le rappel
l'explosion meurtrière et dévastatrice
du 4 août à alimenter la colère des
citoyens contre leurs dirigeants
écoutez la ministre française désarmé
pas se déployer
à partir de demain pour contribuer aux
opérations de celui d'hier déblaiement
du port que nous avons
les opérations département
il y aura là des opérations de
reconnaissance
au port
plèvre
c'est que était
pour pouvoir
débarqué
embarqués et cette question demeure pour
les libanais pourquoi la classe
dirigeante va-t-elle laisser un navire
décharger son stock de nitrate d'uranium
dans le port de beyrouth stock
manifestement à l'origine de l'explosion
le navire battait pavillon moldave et
appartenaient à un homme d'affaires
russe aux chypriotes regarder
[Musique]
papa
or biélorussie la colère ne retombe pas
des manifestants dénoncent toujours la
réélection du président alexandre
loukachenko
des mobilisations réprimées par la force
au total des centaines de blessés
plusieurs milliers de personnes arrêtées
et deux manifestants tués la communauté
internationale dénonce une répression à
des chaînes humaines à minsk
aujourd'hui se sont multipliés pour
dénoncer des violences policières dans
les mains des manifestants une fleur
souvent blanches comme signe
d'apaisement nous sommes ici parce que
nous avons été battu à mort par la
police anti émeute
ils sont en prison maintenant ils ont
été tellement battus de leur crâne ont
été brisées certains sont morts nous
demandons à tout le monde d'arrêter cela
nous voulons que nos mariés nos enfants
rentrent à la maison
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici
s'il vous plaît tout le monde
ecoutez-nous et soutenez nous ne faisons
que défendre la paix le premier ministre
slovène a reçu aujourd'hui mike pompéo
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
l'occasion pour yann escient chat de
donner son avis sur la crise que
traverse actuellement la biélorussie
l'allemagne convoque l'ambassadeur de
biélorussie après les répressions
un peu plus tôt écho aux masses le
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères avait lui aussi fait part de
sa position écouter on les paie solo la
seule solution pacifique à la crise
actuelle en biélorussie et d'organiser
une nouvelle élection avec une forte
présence des missions d'observation
internationales
je pense que si le président loukachenko
est d'accord sur ce point
cela pourrait résoudre l'ensemble de la
situation il y actuellement de
nombreuses discussions entre les
ministres des affaires étrangères et les
états membres sur la façon dont nous
réagissons au développement dans ce pays
je pense qu'il est tout à fait clair que
les actions brutales et l'arrestation de
manifestants pacifiques et même deux
journalistes en biélorussie ne sont pas
acceptables en europe au 21e siècle et
c'est pourquoi il faudra avant tout
augmenter la pression sur ceux qui sont
au bout
et la russie elle parle de tentative
d'ingérence étrangère selon la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe marya
sakharova ces tentatives ont pour but
aussi de diviser la société et
déstabiliser la situation il est dit des
tentatives évident de l'ingérence
extérieure dans les affaires d'un état
souverain pour diviser la société et
déstabiliser la situation
nous avons constaté à plusieurs reprises
l'utilisation de telles méthodes dans
d'autres pays
pour notre part nous appelons chacun à
faire preuve de retenue et de prudence
et on en vient la situation sanitaire en
france et des chiffres à la hausse avec
plus de 2600 69,4 contamination ces
dernières 24 heures à la direction
générale de la santé parle d'une nette
dégradation des indicateurs en une
semaine plus de onze mille cas ont été
recensés au total le kobe de 19 a
contaminé plus de deux cent mille
personnes et en a tué plus de 38000 la
reprise du virus est sur toutes les
lèvres ces dernières semaines selon les
spécialistes de la santé il circule
principalement chez les jeunes en plein
été difficile pour eux de respecter les
gestes barrière explications en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour le docteur bertrand legrand
médecins généralistes une nouvelle vague
pourrait arriver en france d'ici le mois
de septembre si les précautions ne sont
pas prises dès maintenant écoutez le
comme le disaient certains
épidémiologistes concert on a regardé
l'eau monte et on s'est rendu compte que
le tsunami était là quand on avait déjà
de l'eau au genou là on est en train
d'avoir de l'eau à la cheville ça monte
et le tsunami arrivera probablement aux
alentours de septembre
c'est juste une question de calcul il
faut à peu près six semaines pour que ça
se concentrer et donc on voit bien que
la concentration se fait sauf que cette
fois ci on le sait et donc il y en a une
tous une responsabilité individuelle à
effectuer au maximum les gestes
barrières pour ralentir cette montée et
ceux qui le font pas malheureusement
transmettront le virus à leurs proches
en premier économiquement parlant la
prochaine fois il n'y aura pas de
confinement et que donc nous aurons une
surmortalité sur des personnes sur des
populations plutôt âgées c'est un pari
économique mais de toute façon on n'a
plus d'autre de paris donc si on ne fait
pas de ces mesures barrières maintenant
on sait tous très bien comment ça se
finira l actuel gouvernement français de
jean castex qui doit faire face au
spectre de cette reprise de l'épidémie
et le gouvernement le plus coûteux
depuis dix ans selon certaines
estimations le nouveau cabinet devrait
coûter environ un million et demi
d'euros de plus que la dernière équipe
nommée par edouard philippe regarde
[Musique]
en côte d'ivoire la tension monte dans
le pays au sujet de la présidentielle
d'octobre prochain depuis que l'actuel
président alassane ouattara a annoncé sa
candidature à un troisième mandat à des
heurts ont eu lieu aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs villes de côte d'ivoire dont
la capitale abidjan affrontements entre
les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants il y aurait au moins 4
morts entre hier et aujourd'hui selon
des sources sécuritaires et le maire
hier des heurts ont éclaté à daoukro un
couvre-feu a été et dans le reste de
l'actualité internationale en bref et en
images au large de l'île maurice les
opérations de pompage du vraquier vaka
shito sont terminées une information
confirmée par le premier ministre
mauricien
selon les autorités locales ce sont près
de 800 tonnes d'hydrocarbures qui ont
été déversées dans l'océan indien un peu
plus de deux semaines après le naufrage
du navire
les manifestations contre le
gouvernement continue en bulgarie dans
la capitale sofia des milliers de
bulgares se sont rassemblés devant le
parlement
ils ont demandé la démission du premier
ministre boiko borisov et de son
gouvernement
certains ont lancé des oeufs et des
tomates à l'arrivée
les parlementaires à des rassemblements
qui se tiennent depuis maintenant plus
d'un mois dans le pays
aux etats unis un incendie s'est déclaré
dans la ville de santa clarita en
californie un nuage de fumée
impressionnant s'est formée et ce qui
n'était au départ qu'un feu de
broussailles a déjà ravagé plus de 4000
hectares
plus de 300 pompiers ont été dépêchés
sur les lieux
elle les services du shérif du comté de
los angeles ont annoncé l'évacuation
obligatoire des habitations proches du
départ du ce et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi ont fait
un point complet sur l'actualité dans un
peu plus de trente minutes rester avec
nous sur rt français total
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
monde d'avant il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver pensé que
ça allait me rendre plus tolérante et
ben ça m'a rendu plus intolérant alors
parmi elles s'étaient d'expression vous
posez justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]